Germaine is with us in Durham North
Carolina hide Germaine Merry Christmas
how can I help
Hey better than I deserve I I make
around 42 K I have a 115 k mortgage I
have 20,000 and credit cards I have
10,000 I'm a car loan and 48th in
student loans 20k and credit cards
they're in collections and I'm a new
listener so I'm deciding to you know
come up with a budget and a plan to pay
those off and I'm not sure how to go
about it okay
well dude you're just normal but the
problem is normal sucks you are in a
mess you borrowed on everything man I'm
sorry
Wow well we'll help you out here what
you need to do is you said you need to
get on the budget jump on every dollar
calm and download the free online
budgeting tool okay and what I'm going
to do is I'm going to put you through
our nine week class I'm gonna pay for it
called Financial Peace University if I
give you this class will you go
definitely okay are you married no I'm
single and I'm a single father okay good
well you you you go and then someday
when you're rich and famous and
somebody's hurting you pay for them to
go through okay all right so here's what
we're gonna do we're gonna list these
debts smallest to largest I'm gonna put
the student loans on hardship deferral
temporarily so we get caught up on the
credit cards or settle the credit cards
how far behind are you on them at least
ten months okay then you can begin to
settle some of those for pennies on the
dollar
they're probably calling you every 20
seconds aren't they yeah now they're
wearing you out so just take the little
one what's the smallest one maybe twelve
hundred yeah and just get 500 bucks
together and offer it to him when you're
settling with a credit card debt that
you're behind
always get the settled amount in writing
before you give them money and never
give them electronic access to your
checking account because they lie they
will clean you out
you got it you can tell a credit card
collector is lying if their mouth is
moving so you know you've got it you
just you got to protect yourself from
them but you get so you get it in
writing you keep a copy of that email or
whatever it is stapled to the cashier's
check that you used or you have a
receipt of the payment and it's over
it's done forever UK each time you do
that then you've cleaned off one more
now you're gonna be on beans and rice
rice and beans you've got no life and
you're selling stuff working extra
you're not gonna see the inside of a
restaurant unless you're working there
we're not going on vacation
you got a fight scratch claw grind and
clean this mess up and you can do that
it's going to it's doable but if we put
the student loans on hardship deferral
then we've only got $30,000 worth of
debt we're dealing with you can clear
that up everything the student loans in
under two years and then it's probably
gonna take you about another two years
knock these student loans out at some
point we need to work to get your income
up short term and long term and that
means part-time jobs on the short term
anything you can do for extra income
overtime whatever I know you're single
dad we got to figure that part out but
then on top of that long term what are
we doing to get this career in gear
engaged and where you make a little bit
more money to be able to attack these
things and clean this mess up so hold on
I'm gonna have Kelly pick up and we're
going to get you Financial Peace
University it comes with a kit you find
the class near you and go to the class
you've also got all online access for a
year to all the videos and audios and
you've got every dollar Plus which is
the connectivity to the bank for a year
all of that's included in your Financial
Peace University subscription so hold on
Kelly I'll pick it up pick up we'll get
you signed up and get that stuff right
out to you won't get you started on this
as your work
through this Jermaine if you need some
help you call me back if you get scared
or you don't know what to do or your
negotiate with somebody or whatever you
call me I'll help you as you walk
through this thank you for calling in